in the ernesto che guevara hospital in
marigate
doctors fight to keep critical care
patients alive
unlike the city of rio de janeiro in
much of rio state
coronavirus infections continue rising
infections in brazil have surpassed the
2 million mark
it took 4 months to reach 1 million
infections and
less than 1 to double that number
and the death toll is now well past 75
000
yet according to brazil's former health
minister who was sacked by president
bolsonaro for defending confinement
measures authorities and even ordinary
citizens
are not taking coronavirus seriously
enough
people have become uncaring 1300 deaths
a day is like five
jets crashing every day but in people's
minds
it's like they don't understand that
those are five jets packed with people
who could be your mother my sister your
grandson
my great-grandson but the w.h.o
is beginning to see the glass half full
saying that infections are plateauing
and no longer spreading exponentially
it's an opportunity it says to bring the
pandemic under control in latin
america's largest country
whose president is even infected but
downplays the severity of the disease
from the largest to one of the smallest
countries panama
covet 19 is causing havoc
doctors are protesting against what they
say is the government's failure to
provide sufficient protection
we need more supplies than personnel we
don't have enough for the number of
patients
further north in guatemala the death
toll is soaring
after the government relaxed initial
confinement measures
hospital officials say they're on the
brink of collapse
what's killing us is not the virus it's
the indifference of the state
it is the indifference of the health
authorities and as long as governments
ignore
calls for more energetic measures to
control transmission
health experts warn that initial signs
of a slowdown in contagion
will not last to see you newman al
jazeera